and their patronage ex its Greg Alba
here and my name is John so we're going
to be doing the movie news of the week
oh wow what's today's date John is
whatever it's the patio back lobby
wickets in the title past week there's
about five stories YouTube two main ones
patreon gets to make all them the
business it the biggest one let's start
with the biggest ones we got today all
right no Justice League more updates on
the Justice of the league oh look out I
saw him a thing recently about the guy
who's going after Trump oh yeah yeah
that's the obstruction of justice leak
because of his team ah buh impeach
people do it anyway Justice League Danny
Elfman he is set to compose the score
for this movie oh boy and I think that
is a fascinating choice because Danny
Elfman is a very specific type of tone
of any film that he works on I know he's
done a lot of timber and films he did
the Batman and Batman Returns movies as
well
I feel like Tim Burton has a very
distinct tone when he does John Rowe but
there's other stuff like when he does
like dramas and things that aren't Tim
Burton me I'm usually very surprised
yeah well he did spider-man 2 right yeah
of sweets at least I hated the
spider-man 1 and I think that Danny
Elfman bringing his musicals courses
would be very interesting because it is
originally junkie exile who did like Mad
Max fury road which is more along the
lines of what I would expect just asleep
yeah yeah for there like that very you
know I don't know the word for it I mean
it seems like he's got a good grip on
like orchestral elements with with you
know his producing Jack around you know
electronics and yeah stuff like that and
it sounds very dystopian which sounds
like Justice League to me see as events
which Haussmann's very he's kind of
weird he's a little bit on the wackier
kind of fantasy element side with his
music I feel when he does John ray yeah
thing is I know he's got range because
of those those dramas I've seen and this
makes me curious because like Danny
Elfman in this new environment you know
like many years after spider yeah I'm
definitely curious about I don't know if
we're gonna hear all those like Oh like
you know your choruses and stuff but I
think he would do that though I imagine
Danny Elfman would do that he does
effers is kind of fantastical films and
the fact leads on the Batman films I'm
wondering if he when that man has a
certain scene or whatever and if he will
somewhat do a rendition or something
that sounds kind of similar to his
famous Batman tune yeah I think that
would be very exciting and it-it's
really Danielle from five totally
different like whenever I hear Danny
Elfman's music in a movie if I don't
know he composed the music I can usually
guess it's Danny Elfman that's how
distinctive soundtracks are to me and it
is such a specific type of tone and
style that goes over the film that you
know now that Zach Snyder had to step
away in the post-production and Joss
Whedon's taking over the post and Danny
Elfman stepping in I'm really wondering
like I'm a gifting weirdly more excited
for the film not just because not
because like oohs excellent except away
yay it's because of the fact that this
is going to be a interesting
collaborative effort now like it seems
like a lot is changing in the
post-production aspect of it that films
pretty much done in terms of shooting
now I'm wondering how how is this all
going to come together now with this
different crew like big-time creative
collaborators coming again yeah how
cohesive is it going to be and what's it
gonna look like yeah I'm like especially
you know given it seems like you know a
lot of people touch these movies right
now so yeah and also it's not very long
you have to do the score for this movies
when it comes out in just in a few
months from now so I'm wondering you
know I haven't read any reports that are
like oh he doesn't have much time to do
it everyone seems pretty confident that
he'll get a solid soundtrack done just
time I mean it's gonna take over for
what junkie is started or is he just
writing it all up from scratch I'd like
him to write it all up from scratch I
wanted to go like full-on healthman
style okay yeah I could see it I was a
band he was we go going goes real I
don't I don't gotta go to a whole set
you should go oh angle Boingo style the
entire movie do-do-do-do-do-do yeah I I
would hope for that that's really what I
want out of this yeah and and I don't
know like you're dealing with these
elements that where the Justice League
trailer shows you these creatures that
have nightmarish elements to it and even
that scene and bbs the nightmare
sequence and I feel like Danny Elfman is
really good with reviving like that kind
of nightmarish fantasy horror element
type of music as well as why I think
he's worked with Tim Burton so often
photos and so I think especially for
those sequences if he can provide some
like awesome music for the villain
sequences that'll be really cool yeah
definitely I feel like he can amp up the
fantasy vibe yes you know this is
definitely one of those question marks
that I'm excited to see a play out and I
think would like people like Wonder
Woman and Aquaman and yeah he worked on
Batman I feel like he's just a perfect
composer for this film I feel like
Aquaman he could probably write it
pretty cool yeah seem for him I don't
done with musical ways and I ain't know
this sort of thing I know concedes also
he's pretty creative it seems like so I
think is pretty experimental yeah so I
feel like he could I don't know you know
if Aquaman I know they're making it
right now they probably already have
some kind of scheme in place but yeah
like the sounds they're especially I'm
sure he would bring in sort of an
aquatic element you know and it sounds
very spaced out and underwater like you
know because those are always cool
sounds you know Danny Elfman if there's
one thing he's like he's versatile and
it's almost always out of the box
somehow even if it sounds like him so
yeah yeah this is this is definitely
something seems like it'll make this
movie more distinct and not less - all
right people x-men Dark Phoenix is a go
hell yeah hell yeah I'm very excited to
see that care
from x-men apocalypse the last and the
last and witty meet glue yeah they're
all they keep hinting at sanso being
like oh there's some inside you girl we
get it we x-men - and x-men x-men - ends
on Phoenix's gonna be in the next one
yeah next in the last and it yeah
and Simon Kinberg has one of the more
fascinating relationships I think to the
x-men universe out of a lot of people
behind the scenes he does in first movie
he wrote for x-men was x-men the last
name yeah he was co-writer on that's one
of them and and then he worked on the
script for Days of Future past with no
strip for apocalypse he's also doing a
lot of producing for films like Deadpool
name it shows the legion x-force he's
working on as well come and see produces
all of the attention and I believe this
is his directorial debut fun fact I met
Simon Kinberg at his home once Wow
mm-hmm how did that happen I was doing a
job a little job called post Nate's no
way and we are told in orientation to
not you know point out that we know them
if they are someone famous yes but I
said I'm not supposed to say this but
I'm a big fan of your work I lied right
- is it matter if he ever ever since I
subscribe to no no I like a lot of the
work and you and I do I do like most of
the work he's done and I definitely know
his name for sure yeah well I mean he's
one of the big names associated with the
behind the scenes of the x-men franchise
for so many years and so I think it's
cool they'd be the directors he's
writing the script for it and he's
directing it and I can't imagine so I
feel like this is a kind of thing where
this could be a redemption for him in
some way hopefully because Dark Phoenix
was the primary element that x-men fans
were excited for an x-men the last fan
the first script he worked on for the
x-men universe and that was the first
like with the word I'm gonna say a
failure of the x-men franchise
his first downfall oh yeah the first
time we were like whoa I don't know
who's doing the Shiva yeah and so this
is this chance to you know maybe just do
it right this time they get closer to
the comics from my understanding is what
he wants to do and he they also are
getting the entire cast back from like
x-men apocalypse to be in there you know
they got the j-law the the split actor
the shame actor the whole cast back I'm
very excited for and yeah I just think
this would be this should I be I'd be
very surprised if this one is not done
well because there's a lot riding on
this one and simon kingberg seems like
the kind of guys to go okay
last and isn't sure now well this is in
some ways a semi remake not remake more
it's more reboot yeah of the Dark
Phoenix or has to take on that story
second chance to take on that story and
and at the same time he's coming off of
Apocalypse which was not not really
received yet an audience reception
wasn't good for that and it didn't do as
well in box office numbers either so I
imagine he's really gonna put the best
film he could possibly put together for
this specific installing right here yeah
totally I mean and you know that I feel
like he's definitely a jack of many
trades if you look at that IMDB page
he's got a lot of see her do that was a
hell of a liya yeah and he's also a
writer and he's written more than just
the one script you know so I feel like
even if this is his directorial debut it
seems like he's got enough time and
experience around that he could make
something pretty sure and he's also got
a wheel house of people to make these
movies it seems like the kind of guy he
is that guy from behind the camera that
I would want like when I heard that he
was trying to direct an excellent movie
and he wanted to do this I was
immediately in full support of him doing
it yeah he seems like the right kind of
guy to do it yeah I definitely want to
see how he handled and I hope he doesn't
get a job because you know it's it's
nice to have somebody that's been along
with this series yeah for better and
worse you know for so long you know
because he
produces Legion to which everyone's
losing their mind about right now and
though I think it's fascinating too
because he's worked on so many scripts
as the writer or as a producer helping
the develop and develop a story it I
think it'd be fascinating to see like
okay let's see what kids oftentimes when
a person writes a script it's always a
director's vision it's the director's
medium they're interpreting the script a
very specific way in their mind and
that's what we were seeing on the big
screen yeah so that's why a lot of times
the blame will go a lot more to the
director like he worked on days that I
worked on the last stand but you know
everyone blames Brett Ratner for the
development right yeah and I want to do
simon kingberg [ __ ] that bubs
yeah Brett Ratner in the studio yeah
exactly you know so I'm interested to
see okay now that he has worked on so
many of the scripts let's see him bring
the vision that he keeps like because I
can imagine that oftentimes when he
writes scripts it turns out different
than how he he was were originally
imagining when he was writing the story
so that good for him good well and also
to like you know they say they want to
take this in a drastically different
direction and you know with every X -
film
yeah the problem is I got a taste for
that in Apocalypse and you know they're
talking about going more cosmic with
this news story and I know that in
fashion right now because of things like
Doctor Strange and guardians of the
galaxy and we're expanding these more
and part of what x-men apocalypse lost
for me was is oh it's on the scale that
all the other movies are on now so it
needs to be a more interesting to make
that jump work and so I'm really curious
to see how they're going to do this
because this is also centering around my
least favorite performance in that movie
and I just didn't like song with what
she did with that and it's not even her
fault I don't know like I don't know if
it was the writing of that character or
if it was her performance or what but
yeah I was excited to see that character
come back and she didn't do anything for
me no I've never really thought that
writing of Jean Grey in the movies
been that great yeah and even with famke
janssen I didn't really feel like she
was great yeah do it yeah and I I didn't
know as much about the comics when I
started watching extant movies you know
so there was stuff I was more forgiving
of but especially now the thing is - I'm
wondering how much he's and it's even
pretty invested in the story because
that's a cool opportunity if you're if
you've got like the worst Jean Grae
installment and now you get a chance to
redo it like a cool opportunity yeah
alright patronage X thanks for tuning in
to this week's movie news of the week
thank you you're in next week because
there's always movie news coming out I'm
sure it'll be another cinematic universe
thing to talk about oh hell yes can't
get enough of the cinematic universes
and comic book movies where is this day
where we actually talk about some
original piece of material coming out
hey man who needs original movies when
you have things you already know what
they are yeah all about franchises
familiarity and you can catch our full
movie news of the week over on patreon
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell that is John Humphrey
at dat John Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram social media manager of Blum
house and as always I'm the Greg Alva on
Instagram and Twitter also for you guys
who actually stuck around to the outro
put up a reaction to that Siegel's bad
lip reading song it got blocked
immediately by YouTube when I've tried
putting up a few months ago it's a lab
on patreon just for you guys oh look out
much love